hey guys welcome back to the Samsung
stage we're back again and this time
with a brand-new game just announced at
e3 I've got John with me hi John how you
doing nice to meet you hey man I'm doing
really well thanks for us you know
you're the first person day to ask me
how I'm doing haha you're my favorite
already but enough by that defenders of
time this is your game you've just
announced at e3 what is defenders of
time defenders of time is a multiplayer
tower defense 4 on 4 a co-op and
competitive okay you can play any number
of players from one all the way up to 8
and our game remains balanced even if
it's one on four okay so tell me about
that kind of tower defense game play
exactly how does it work like oh yeah
how'd you start you start off so when
you start off the game up we have a
bunch of tests or a basic single player
maps a lot of people we've found over a
testing really don't like jumping into
multiplayer it multiplayer it's actually
easier but I'll get into that in a
second that's right we got a bit of
noise spill from other stage don't worry
about it i will just showed over Chris
waters showed him down there sounds
great uh you start out any single player
maps so when you're going download the
game you can actually play single for it
player for free okay and you go into
these single player maps and you start
out and there's you'll see a couple of
lines streaming down and that's where
the enemies are tracking along find out
that you can place towers along these
paths and actually alter them it's a
full-blown amazing tower defense we
played a lot of tower defenses and we
didn't really like how you couldn't
block the paths okay we made sure that
we could do that in this game every
single map is like that anyway once you
get into the game uh in the
single-player mode you're free to then
go and try the multiplayer mode
multiplayer mode is where it's really at
okay so what so what was you kind of
what was your inspirations for but it
for defendants at I'm like you know what
can I tards games truck tire defense
games you looked at before and you're
like oh I want to pick bits from that
and this is really tough of the field
we're going for so what really started
it was back in the day
sure half the people here remember
warcraft 3 i'm sure sure everybody does
so at or winter mall argyll TD that's
even older cube defense i used to play
those four hours with my friends I used
to try to get my friends together just
to play that in a lan scenario because
it was wonderful uh when i came back to
tower defense after being in the video
game industry for a while we're mostly
left with tablet and mobile versions and
i really wanted that experience that I
had back in the day there's some left on
starcraft but it's not as rich as it
used to be so we wanted to bring that
back and really bring it up a whole to a
whole new level have you guys I've
released any like trailers or gameplay
or anything to this point or is it still
is it too early to really show off yeah
you just just initially talking about it
was all of the stuff is getting posted
online as we speak we started our
operations about a week ago oh wow so
this is new new music guess yeah so
what's it like bringing this this thing
you've been hell are you working on
Ashley honey we've been working on full
production since august of last year we
were doing pre-production since november
of the year before it was it was quite a
sea bean you've been busy away behind
the scenes and what's what's it like
narrative be able to like finally talk
about it at at e3 you know like the
biggest games event of the year like as
i feel what's wonderful about it is it's
been something that we know that people
would really enjoy so now that we're
able to really properly tell people
about it we've had people in for testing
but it's wonderful to see them all right
up as they play it's it makes my day
fantastic and how should we action being
you know the people who have a VIP yes
you have it here in a capacity to build
and come and see or even come and play
we have for multi to full multiplayer
games going all the time and eight
single-player stations running at our
booth over in the south hall
uh it's when people walk away they come
back they bring their friends back Oh
wonderful it's been really it's been
quite a response did you ever see that
I'm just remembering at the last cat
tower defense game I heard about they
were showing your fair with oculus
support did you guys think you know did
you ever see that as you as you can put
oculus rift on you could play this tower
defense game you could like lean down
into the game and like and see what was
happened did you guys consider like
jumping on with oculus tech and bringing
that in I'm so excited for oculus rift I
can't tell you it's one of the coolest
things to happen to video game in a long
time okay but anybody who's developer
console will tell you if a cup if the
peripheral isn't required if it's a
gamepad yeah most people don't buy it so
we have a small team we're a very tiny
self-publishing indie studio I've got 13
guys and one of those is our payroll
department so you guys are so we haven't
had time for it but we'd love to we can
see the game running now and so tell
explain what's going on here so this map
we were calling Babylon right now it's
uh it's loosely based on the Hanging
Gardens we got this ready just before e3
happen so this is what we consider a
simple entry map there are six entry
points on this map but there's only one
exit you can see the person driving
right now is showing off actually our
drawing features but i'll get to in a
second okay but he's routing all the
guys around the towers twice if possible
that's really really important in our
game the towers aren't efficient enough
on their own that's the metrical uses
efficiency how the oceans is a tower
when it's placed the lower the level it
is the less efficient it is and in the
wrong scenario it's inefficient like a
single target in a multi-target
scenarios not as efficient as it could
be but right now he's trying to build a
maze to keep the game going so we can
keep talking about you guys is this
being played live now I thought I was
just it's been played live right
I see I thought this was like a free
record even know this is this happening
right now yes so cross your fingers once
hope he doesn't die he's actually one of
the best players we have but he's trying
to get used to everything what's his
name he's playing its John lamborn 1
John all right well ring for you buddy
he does he does a map development
programming art he is mother bleep like
smile Jen just said he just wrote wheels
the screen there that was great while
John is trying not to die if you guys
are watching at home and would like to
ask some questions or put some questions
to John here on stage just they're the
best we do that would be to tweet at me
my twitter handle is at cam fraz rob a
taxi a.m. fri z Ro be and i will throw
them straight edge on a hill knock him
away sounds great billet pick so what
was it was his strategy so what's John
what's john's main strategy here do you
think so his strategy is um John could
you bring up the the flight paths real
quick all right again so right now you
can see the flight paths he's trying to
get areas on the map where the flight
paths are intercepting the ground paths
which are around the edges gotcha where
and he can pass the ground around twice
later on if he survives long enough are
actually I see he's got some now we've
got some light towers that have an
effect on them called gravity where air
paths can be shifted as far as we know
where the first our defenses ever try
this John if you could play some more
white towers so what a white terrasse de
so the white towers their primary
function is as a force multiplier they
they act to pull in air paths they
reveal stealth units later ones can
reveal a phasing units which our phasing
units they phase in d phase at certain
points in the game but you can force
them to deface using certain white
towers so
we also have a really cool feature in
here for multiplayer called that we're
just term drawing which allows you to
draw on the map itself we used to play a
game called company of heroes I'm sure a
bunch of people are familiar with that
guy Oh beats John John your it in so
well we think I was probably artful
before he distracted sorry I district we
distracted him the game is not easy a
hundred percent of the time so uh yeah
but it was great to have a great to have
a sea of it there I mean it but tell you
tell me just a bit about the kind of
drawing feature so what was why is that
in there what's that all about the users
say fire yeah spired so we used to play
a company purest up and what would
happen is my friends and I would get
together and we'd all gather around and
we'd go okay we always like to play
defensively against the computer okay
well we're going to go up here I'm going
to go here you're gonna go down here we
need to go and cross in the center five
minutes in right before they capture
that third bridge and blow it up we need
to do that so we prep it in the
beginning we use to say wouldn't it be
really cool if we could show each other
and really is just describing it through
words there's very difficult but we have
to be there it's really hard otherwise
so what we did was we took this and we
said okay well how would we do we
accomplish the things that we want to do
first we have to have integrated
microphone support and second we need a
way to draw and King very easily the
drawing teacher pinging pinging is
common in a lot of games but drawing if
you hold down shift you can actually
draw out your maze before or during the
game via the drawing only lasts for a
moment but it's enough to show somebody
its hat what's happening the other thing
is you'll hold down control you can draw
in the UI itself oh wow so you can say
hey look I need you to give me money and
somebody goes how do I give you money
but up in the upper left no no other
left no upper left tell you rather I
know we've all had
moments yeah all I need to do is hold
down control and circle it and it works
you can see it on the screen right now
yep that's 60 m tell me more about some
of the units and some of the things you
can put down you can kind of build too
so you got the white flower as you
mentioned but what else have you got so
you have two sides in our game i'll
start with the towers okay you have
white towers which are a force
multiplier your green towers which are a
radius area of attack the tower they
only work against ground and they're
very effective but they have to be
clumped together if you don't have at
least three or four units they they're
just not worth it so right in the
beginning they're perfect then you have
black towers which do amazing signal
target damage but they're really really
mediocre against group dense groups you
have lightning towers which are good
against medium densities of units like
we're seeing right here and there are
red towers as well okay red towers do a
ranged area of effect attack but when
you can't quite reach it or you need to
hit air they're not as effective as
green but there but they can hit air as
well also we are the last time we have
is slowing which is one of our very
favorites we've got different types of
slowing one doesn't outright freeze and
one does align slow and the other one
the base level one actually does this
range slow that can attack air so we
find ourselves in the very end of the
game actually using level one towers to
hit things who well I should got a few
questions have come to you on twitter if
you don't mind if I just throw them at
you Joan know that so we have cabin on
twitter says heritage defensive time
compared with similar tower defense game
Tyra madness hi so it's much time at
this I haven't played our house madness
but I can tell you how we're a little
different from other one go on yeah our
tower defense games only tend to last 10
to 15 minutes okay there are really
really quick so you'll find a lot of
smaller tower defenses do you last two
three five minutes but they tend to be a
slower experience
one of the problems that John's happen
having right now is this map is actually
a multiplayer map that we broke down for
single okay uh but it hasn't been a
tweaked for single-player loan so what's
happening right now is he's getting the
money that three players would get so
three players get money and then the
commander which I can tell you all about
in a minute doesn't get any money but he
controls how the other player what the
other team gets he's getting all the
money and he's barely able to keep up
that's part of how we balance a player
if one person drops out you're okay yeah
yeah but if somebody gets together for
boxes and drops him out on purpose to
reduce communication lag he's suddenly
going to get hit with a ton of extra
money that he's not going to be able to
handle I see okay we got a few more
questions here it's gonna keep throwing
them at you so this one comes from
Stuart Hopkins this is a good question
actually says can users create their own
levels and share them so you get
something that we talked about and it's
something that we would love to do it's
something that really extends the life
of a game today we have a couple of
development issues with that we have a
we have effectively a 12-person
development team so one of the problems
is is our game is based on unity which
should make it very easy Norder to test
out the levels you need to use unity pro
which means that you'd have to buy unity
Pro before you could actually mark up
the levels but it's something we'd like
to do in the future so you neither have
to find a way of you have to build your
own tools i guess to enable people to
build the levels without unity pro or
something like that which says I gotta
wear today our engineers can do it it's
just a matter of time yeah fantastic all
right just got one more question than
that a is just basically just about
platform so you know people like the
look of defenders a time where can they
work in the player and when in the
future do you visit this being finished
so we're releasing in august-september
for twenty dollars okay step 7 okay uh
and on that point if you uh if you own
the game and you have three other
friends or one other friend that you
want to play with you they don't have to
buy the game
really yeah I can just say hey would you
like to play with me I don't own the
game okay well that's okay I do and
we'll play together it's a it's the old
starcraft spawning system more or less
but you can play full online and if you
don't have single player you can play
too so you'll be able to pick up the
game at defenders of time calm or four
dash lights calm those are two sites and
it'll be a vailable august/september
sometime in there my engineers maybe
promise not to give an exact date okay
and Sony but and yeah I'm what what
systems universe play it up baby right
if we're releasing primarily on mac and
pc pc yet we would like to expand in the
future possibly the mobile but we
promised that we would make a perfect
game for one platform and then we'd
expand from there so cross your fingers
it may or may not appear on those other
team Oh Jonas been a pleasure having you
on stage and talk about a brand new game
that's I think it's the first time it's
happened for me to see three wheels you
know talk about sewing this it's
completely new completely fresh and just
get be able to sit down with someone and
able to show off so only be working on
so hard for so long it's real pleasure
so thanks so much so much for having me
we're excited to be is be great and
we've had lots questions on Twitter so
it's obviously quite a lot of excitement
so excellent job well done fantastic
guys thank you so much for your
questions I mean makes it much easier
for me you know eventually I run out of
questions but I've always got you guys
to send some to me so I appreciate that
but we're not quite done yet I've got
one more demo on this stage before
Christopher waters jump silver in one
giant leap from the other sign of the
gains Buck booth all the way over here
and he's got a bunch more games but my
final game will be coming to in just a
minute is gonna be payday two big bank
heist so make sure you come back for
that we will of course return in just a
few minutes don't go anywhere